now we have some good news yep i'm fine
excited about this
henry caviland talks to return as
superman in
upcoming dc movie yes yes yes and he did
an
awesome job as superman i gotta say i
really liked him as superman
he's my favorite superman really of all
of the superheroes there's not that much
to pick
from yeah that's a good point yeah he
does a great job he does he makes an
awesome superman
and i actually liked ben affleck as
batman i'm excited i did
okay i absolutely did i got to give it
to him he it wasn't bad it wasn't bad
i x and i went into it thinking it was
going to be bad and then i was like oh
i liked it it wasn't bad um i'm not i
don't think he's the best batman
no who's the best batman no that's tough
but uh
i think christian bale killed it dude i
was i i i want to lean on
lean on that one for sure because of the
difficult thing is i think val
uh uh valkyr
val kilmer val kilmer yeah he was okay
um
michael michael keaton michael keaton
was good was good yeah but
the thing the reason i want to say
christian bale is just because i really
like that trilogy and the dark knight
is one of the best i mean yeah it was a
different time too but i
was in the area of our era of really
good cinematics i'll tell you the movies
you know not george clooney oh i forgot
he was batman
yeah forgettable yeah that was not on my
list no
no yeah not george clinton you know
those movies i think chris
it's christian bale michael keaton and
vile kilmer
and then i guess i don't know i'd put
but i was like oh actually you know what
yeah ben affleck
and michael keaton i'm gonna put michael
keaton right on second
yeah he didn't move his neck though you
know what i mean he's like well that was
the suit i know
you know he had no choice right right
all right yeah i like ben affleck
um and i wonder if he'll come back
that'd be cool i'd really love to see
shazam
superman yes shazam was was great
suzanne was awesome
they're working on shazam too yup
excited i love that movie that was a
great movie it was dc's
like turn around yeah actually that
might be my favorite dc movie
you know what they've been trying to
because joker actually is dc right but
it's not the d
it's not the dc eu okay okay so so
oh the joker is incredible or just joker
is that what it is
simply joking amazing the incredible
moment
the last joke is just so amazing and
there's a meme so i'm going to spoil the
snacks i'm assuming everyone's already
seen it fair warning i haven't seen it
he's ruining it there's a little meme
comic where
joker is sitting in a chair and they're
like they're drawn as like
he's like portly and like you know cute
looking
and he's angry and he says what do you
get when you cross you know a mentally a
mentally ill
man with a society that you know ignores
him or whatever
and then the tv hosho smiles and says in
canada you get health care and we take
care of you
and then they're both smiling and it
says the end oh it's spoiled hold on
hold on before we move on i gotta give
it up to chat again
chat you are on fire oh gosh
adam west adam west adam
west come on come on oh my goodness
he's incredible he's gonna be og
and they're right because i didn't even
i didn't even think about this i didn't
even think about it how dare you
adam west uh
first and foremost the the kooky funny
nature of the original batman series
yes amazing silliness of it yeah was was
was actually well done
yeah it carried perfectly and adam west
is like he was a legend man
totally favorite family guy character
yeah absolutely
oh my gosh oh he's candy no that was
james woods oh that's james what yeah
all
right
no uh uh adam west adam west is wait
which one
adam west so many memorable memorable
moments
so okay now we can move on all right
henry cavill is back
henry cavill in talks to return as
superman in upcoming dc movie
that would be awesome i liked man of
steel yeah
it was really good really good i really
liked chris maloney in it
you know is that the bad guy no no he's
which one's he he was the military
officer
he was the guy who was in law and order
svu so can you think of who that is
one of my favorite scenes in that movie
um law order svu man
stapler i don't watch man of steel he
plays like the main military dude
okay i bet i'll see his face and be like
ah of course there's a scene what's his
name again
christopher maloney yeah christopher
maloney there's a scene
in man of steel that i is awesome
so what's the name of that evil woman
the evil kryptonian woman i forget her
name
it's been so long oh this guy's awesome
yeah yeah yeah he's great
there's a scene where like his
helicopter goes down and then the
kryptonian woman in armor is standing
there
and he's like sweating and holding the
knife like he there's nothing else he
can do
and everyone around him just died got
got and he's like
and he flinches that was awesome scene
it's like you're just a dude that's a
kryptonian you're gonna die but he's
like ready to go i love that scene that
was a cool scene you're right i
i what i really like about like the
marvel universe
is when regular people are put in these
tough situations why i like batman yeah
i like iron man yeah
so i like a falcon and so when he's just
like a regular military guy with a knife
up against this super-powered alien and
he's like i'm going for it i don't care
i'm
i'm going to do it she's going to snap
her fingers and you're going to be dust
but he's like not going to run he's not
going to whimper he's going to stand his
ground that was an awesome scene that's
awesome ursa
was that her name yeah i'm not sure yeah
i want to watch that movie now
yeah let's watch it that was a good
movie yeah i i'm just i wish they would
have done this
the dc universe proper mm-hmm do a
batman movie
no no you know what it feels like
they're realizing their mistakes
yes they're looking back and going fix
it we should have done it this way
actually you know what everyone wants
the snyder cut let's give it to them
and not only that they're gonna legitly
do it correctly
oh let's just let's go too right why
don't you go ahead drop drop it we're
gonna read it all right so this was the
tweet darkseid's coming to
uh oh turns out he was always there
and they cut him out of the movie so
there's a clip right here that makes
sense
zack snyder said he's coming to hbo max
now some people are mad look at this
dark side doesn't use weapons you
clearly have no clue about the character
okay okay all right
calm down we don't want to get comic
book guy from the simpsons all on jack
on zack snyder well that doesn't look
like an axe
it looks more like a staff of some sort
yeah i don't know all i know is it might
not be a weapon
it looks like they were originally going
to have darkseid flashlight
that's what remember was complaining
like why did they do steppenwolf i know
you're right i don't care about that guy
this is what it needed it probably just
took too too much it's like sidetrack
from the the main story
warner brothers interference i'll tell
you what man here's what that happened
i bet snyder was like we're gonna do our
justice league we're gonna get dark side
it's gonna be a big epic
and then they they probably did it and
then some guy was like well why waste
the villain now
use the other guy and then we'll do
another one we'll make more money that's
and that
sounds like it yeah yeah and he was
probably like no
you know and that's why
and so now that that still looks like
they had him there the whole time
yeah i agree i'm excited for that story
well let's
let's see what's going on with this this
henry cavill thing yeah okay they say
uh he isn't hanging out with superman
kate just yet sources confirmed a
variety man of steel actors and talks to
return as clark kent in an upcoming dc
comics movie
so it's not gonna be superman but it's
also gonna be a new movie though with
him as superman
dude superman versus shazam would be
awesome yeah yeah maybe not of versus
but the cool thing about superman
fighting shazam is that superman is weak
to magic what about
black adam that's the same uh that's the
same universe isn't it black adam is the
is one of the villains
for uh shazam it's like one of the main
dudes right okay
yeah but he's getting his own movie
though isn't he i think i think he's
getting his own
yeah there's gonna be shazam too and
then black adam has a movie
isn't it sure i thought so maybe maybe
i'm wrong i don't know because
he's the villain for she's in yeah yeah
i think the rock was supposed to play
black adam oh he is good he is playing
yeah he's confirmed yeah he's a he's a
perfect
dude he's perfect i'm excited for this
all right
let's see who who plays suzanne zach
right zach zachary
it is it's he's getting his own movie
black adam really looking at the imd
right here imdb
oh cool because his his origin story was
that he was given the powers you know
a long long time ago and then he went to
his head and he became he has the shazam
power
right right yeah okay different
different uh shazam each letter stands
for some god or whatever
oh cool his were based on like egyptian
gods i think or something like that ah
dope yeah
so what's this what's this movie they
say uh so schneider announced the long
rumored snyder cut of justice league
that's awesome uh insiders tell variety
cavill wouldn't be suiting up for the
director's cut
but rather a cameo in one of dc's
upcoming films which includes aquaman
two
the suicide squad and the batman and oh
so it's just a cameo
i'm excited for the suicide squad
there's a certain uh there's a certain
someone that i'm not i'm not interested
in
seeing yeah that's true that the lady
who uh who
who poops on the bed uh i wasn't gonna
go there
i went there bro you went there i dove i
dove right in because because you know
what you don't you know what happens
when you say it
it becomes a segment about amber hurt
poop down to bed no no and moving on
both the batman is that that new movie
that's coming out that was supposed to
come out they've been teasing the new
bat suit
i forget who's yeah but it's robert
robert patrick yeah robert patterson
right
pattinson pattinson the guy who was in
twilight yeah that guy
yeah that guy anything else harry potter
i've never seen twilight or harry potter
he gets killed by voldemort come on
you're millennials
i don't read the book i don't i don't
know i don't know i don't know what
you're talking about
let's see how do i look up this guy's
name wait yeah that's it there we go
pattinson
so this is a guy what's he what's it
what's he doing
oh he's in it oh
you know what actually on that note i am
so excited about that movie
anytime i see anything for it i breeze
right past you can't read it i
no i don't want i don't want to know
anything because because
i know i'm going to like that movie i
don't want to i don't want to see
anything i want to go in completely
blind i haven't i
every time i see a trailer i turn i walk
out of the room hold on hold on hold on
do you know what it's about i've seen at
like i oh man oh this looks
wait what is this oh sorry i gotta get
out of here no i don't want to see it so
do you know the general premise
no i don't really even know what it's
about then why then why don't you wait
what do you mean
what do you mean what do i mean what if
you don't like it so it's a christopher
nolan movie okay yeah it's fair no no
i'm sorry man we need to be it's good we
need to be able to talk about what the
movie is about
right now why so we're people we're
talking about superman distractible
all right bring it back to superman let
me just say you want to do a segment on
it i can prepare myself
tenet looks awesome sure we'll leave it
at that and it looks awesome we'll leave
it at that i can't
wait i like christopher nolan's i want
the theaters back open yep
yes and we can actually do stuff about
like
movie reviews like we used to remember
those things yeah i know it's fun
remember stuff
those are the old uh the the old times
the old times yes
timothy this is very important i need
you to know this i really want
that movie to be the first movie we see
when we get out of lockdown
wait when does it come out is correct
because i have been waiting to see that
movie ever since i saw
when does it come out yeah i'm nervous
when does it go anybody know
july 17th oh we better be out before
then oh yeah
we should be we didn't didn't amc go out
in here though
i don't know that's the amc right there
yeah i know so
didn't they close down like indefinitely
or something i'm not sure i thought we i
thought we talked about that but
the batman oh yeah the batman so it is
the batman that he's in so this is the
one that
uh henry cavill might be
young batman yeah i don't know i don't
know how it's gonna work
it seems like it would be right because
he's he's a younger
younger man he's in his 30s i think
right robert pattinson yeah mm-hmm i
have his uh what could be right what is
he
what is he 50 i didn't know he's like
35.
34. oh he's younger than me oh he's a
spring chick
well i thought you were 34. i am but i
was born his birthday's in may and
mine's in march
oh you got him by two months good for
you good for you buddy
so i guess he's not going to be a young
man but it's going to be like it's going
to be
like not the peak like the of his career
maybe equal
yeah stuff yeah i'm going to be prequel
you know i guess i guess they need to do
it
but then what do they do do they bring
back ben affleck if they do do justice
league two
yeah i don't know probably well this it
probably is going to be a standalone
thing
the batman you know it's so obvious they
wanted to beat avengers so they rushed
it
yeah they had i see that yeah they could
have done cyborg
mother box then they could have done uh
wonder woman two
mother box and that but instead they
were like let's just do it all at once
and oh there they are it's like dude you
need to introduce these things and let
people get
custom like nobody thought iron man was
going to be huge because iron man was
not a top-tier marvel character i guess
my understanding of it and i could be
wrong about this so marvel fans don't
get mad at me
uh my understanding was that marvel had
sold a lot of their characters
away um okay like x-men to fox and
spider-man to sony
and so they were like who do we have
because we're gonna make a movie and
they did the hulk
so like marvel was basically like all of
these studios that did these movies have
failed and they've done the characters
wrong
so if we get funding into a movie it'll
work so they did the whole the hulk was
kind of like man they did an iron man
and that was a hit i mean robert downey
jr was
he made it happen seriously i think that
that's the reason it was as good as it
was because he
he played stark so well he is stuck yeah
i was like definitely i thought i i this
could be apocryphal but
i heard that like he called his agent
and said that's me and he like walked in
he's like i'm tony stark
oh right oh in the beginning that's what
i heard he told them
that wouldn't surprise me and like he
played it so well
yeah dude robert robert is amazing
yeah i can't believe he he basically
saved the marvel company
because they were they were in trouble
they went bankrupt or whatever oh really
yeah and they started selling off the
rights of the characters because they
needed money
oh yeah yeah something like that and
then the mcu
yeah what an awesome movie dude you
know i didn't realize because it's been
a decade but i was going back and
looking at all these like i was watching
an older movie
and i'm like i wonder how much this
movie made in the box office and it was
like a 35 million
budget and it made like 50 million and
that was a success and i was like whoa
only made only profit of 15 mil 50. oh
no no no they made 50 but it cost 35.
marketing stuff they probably made less
than that
yeah that's a good point well the reason
i say whoa is you look back at movies in
the 2000s and
you know the 2000s and the 90s and stuff
and
they had smaller budgets and made way
less money then you look at marvel and
it's like
they have a 200 million budget made a
billion dollars like every single movie
they've done
yeah it's insane and so that's the thing
about the the what people don't realize
about the dc
movies is that they're like they're not
really good it's like
let me let me let me pull up uh a list
of dc movies no let me let me uh
i am interested in that though i gotta
do that on the side here
let me pull up justice league here all
right we're googling
[Music]
i'm duck duck going so here oh sorry
sorry for the record
there you go tim's back on justice
league was a 300 million
budget it made 657.9 million dollars
so even if you compare this to like
movies a long time ago
that was like a tenfold you know amount
of money
a lot of other movies i would you know
maybe i'm wrong i mean there were high
budget movies you know back in the day
but it seems like we're really in this
era of the billion dollar blockbuster
yeah so they know they're like just keep
making more dc movies because even if
they're bad people can go see them
because they love it like aquaman was
just good enough for me yeah the ending
was a spectacular
visuals yeah it was a good movie the
music was kind of weird
i'm looking wonder woman was awesome i
didn't think about the music of
i i liked aquaman one it was a good
movie oh you know i'm really angry man
because they had to postpone wonder
woman
oh 1984. oh man yep man that
that looks good i'm excited to see that
movie i know yeah where are we at gal
gadot let's see what's she up to
filmography oh i like her a little less
after this so wonder woman 1984 let's
see
what's the what's the wonder woman is
the perfect example
of um a powerful female
lead and it's an awesome movie every
everyone i've talked to is like yeah
that movie was awesome it's like you
don't need to it wasn't like social
justice
you're feminist i mean there was
essences of it because it was done right
it but they it was done correctly yeah
it was dope
august props on that august 14th for a
wonderful 1984.
i'm dude i love the trailer for this
movie i'm just excited for this
you like the uh remake remake of that
song blue monday yeah yeah yeah yeah
so good freaking love that orchestral
blue monday
so i was looking up uh dc movies that
are coming out and
and wonder woman's right at the top and
i guess they just announced green
lantern core
really the green lantern corpse we gotta
get a cameo a group of humans joined the
green lantern corps an alien interspace
police force that protects the uniforce
that's uh i always liked a green lantern
we gotta get a cameo for my rentals on
that one
that would be hilarious yes even if it
even if it's just five
seconds doesn't matter gotta have some
cameo in that please ryan
he's great he's hilarious i follow him
and he's he's a funny dude he's the best
celebrity
he's one of the one of the best funny
humble self-deprecating
yeah yeah it's true and just he's got
great qualities
and deadpool was like on the mark he was
deadpool yeah he did such a good job
yeah
that was the joke they were like uh i
guess in the comic they said deadpool is
a combination of ryan reynolds mixed
with sharpay
or something like that that's great and
ryan was like really advocating for
deadpool and like
wow man no he made that movie happen
yeah like
but think about think about ryan
reynolds uh stature
his voice yeah he's deadpool he's so
deadpool
that's so true it's like ryan uh like
robert downey jr is iron man and yeah
he did the same thing to deadpool is
deadpool yeah awesome i will i will go
and see 50 deadpool movies if you keep
making them totally
it's something the silly fun is
hilarious i would say the same thing
with iron man but they killed him off
yeah why'd they have to kill him he
can't keep like the
the fact of the matter is both of them
can't keep doing it you know what i mean
but
i mean dude pirates of the caribbean is
hilarious i love how many others there's
five of them they're doing more
pirates yeah are they bringing them back
i believe they're better
than jenny that's freaking better yeah
for johnny yes
you go johnny thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
we do the show live
monday through friday at 8pm if you want
to catch the full show tune in to this
channel subscribe
hit the like button or check us out on
itunes and spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode